the attack came as people were having
their evening meal in one of the few
restaurants still operating in the
eastern city of kramatosk
y
I ran here after the explosion because I
rented a cafe here everything has been
blown out there's nothing no windows no
doors all I see is destruction fear and
horror this is the 21st century
among the nine killed was a child and
two teenagers a one-year-old was also
injured
all the destruction it's shocking to see
in real life when you see it in photos
it's different what you see on TV
doesn't even begin to show what you see
in real life
Twisted Metal and Rubble is All That
Remains as rescue teams tried to look
for survivors
ambulances took the injured away
the Shockwave from missile damaged
neighboring buildings and scent glass
flying the city used to have a
population of 150 000 but since the war
started many have left
it's 25 kilometers from the front line
to the east of the country modern
Weaponry means it's well within range of
Russian guns
each such manifestation of Terror proves
over and over again to us and to the
whole world that Russia deserves only
one thing as a result of everything it
has done defeat and a Tribunal fair and
legal trials against all Russian
murderers and terrorists
it's not the first time the city has
been targeted it routinely comes under
attack from Russia last year 63 people
were killed as they waited outside the
train station officials in keep have
been monitoring recent events in Russia
the attacking crimeators is a reminder
that despite the Mutiny by the Wagner
group it has no impact on the front
lines here and the war continues Russia
continues to strike Ukraine with fatal
consequences Assad bake al-jazeera Kiev
Ukraine